and with quantum physics the rules of
clicking a little particle and seeing
where it goes are so wonky that you will
you won't know where that particle goes
it might tunnel through a barrier the
plant on your wall could just move
through the wall all of a sudden those
types of things happen on the quantum
scale so weird things happen and you
need special math to describe those
weird behaviors so that's quantum
physics and then over here is the
opposite so it's the opposite of like
something really tiny would be something
really really big something big enough
to noticeably affect this the curvature
of space and time those are things like
black holes the sun neutron stars
supernovas like the most massive things
in the universe are described by the
language of general relativity and we
still have not been able to unify those
there's some places where the languages
don't match
foreign
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today was pretty intense and a lot of
information and a lot of
thought-provoking topics today's
interview was with Diana Cowan she's a
science communicator and a YouTuber she
has like two and a half million people
that follow her on YouTube she has she
makes amazing videos explaining
everything from crystals to time to dark
matter I mean you name it she's done
videos on it she's really fascinating so
if you're interested at all in physics
she or how the world Works let's just
like boil it down to something more
simple like how the world Works check
her out so today we went all over the
place of course we're explaining like
generally what physics is and then and
different kinds of physics so got
Newtonian physics as well as quantum
theory and then we got into like stuff
like time Dimensions crystals fractals
dark matter of course it's like how are
we going to know if we are in a
Multiverse or just if it's just one
universe and that's just how it all
works but these are really interesting
questions and so uh we had a blast
um we chit chatted on we like ended the
interview and then it kind of just kept
going
um as she's just as curious as I am
about these things so uh ultimate lesson
is like stay curious so enjoy this
interview of staying curious and being
in the mystery of what's what's really
happening and what's not and essentially
at the end of the interview getting to
like a really fundamental great question
which is are we in a simulation or are
we not so she explains what she thinks
about that so enjoy
um thanks for stopping by thanks for
listening
um please hit subscribe uh it really
tells me that you resonate with the
information and the interviews that I'm
doing uh leave comments about what you
think hit the bell for notifications
when we have a new episode drop yeah The
Theory of Everything do you think that
we're ever going to figure that out in
this lifetime our lifetime
um gosh
um I'm gonna go with unfortunately no
that's like the biggest disappointment
that you could ever give a curious
person right first of all this is the
this is the coolest thing to to chat
with you about science I think that's
what we're gonna talk about I don't know
but that's why we're definitely and I'm
not going to ask you about the physics
of a race car trust me but I've always
been fascinated with the universe and I
think in another life I was or will be a
cosmologist and I just love I've always
looked up to the stars and thought how
does it all work and my biggest question
is what what is reality like what is
this experience of being a human being
and
um so uh and and therein lies a lot of
physics and and and so maybe I'm curious
like what's the definition of physics
and then I kind of want to get into the
the Realms of physics with Newtonian
physics and quantum theory
oh yes okay so you want to Dive Right In
deep
um so I think the textbook definition of
physics is not the most interesting
maybe the most the most interesting way
to think about physics is still like the
biggest unanswered questions and it was
your very first question you threw at me
which is what is the answer to
everything
um specifically we don't even know what
mass is yet so you know your face your
hair your car we don't know what it is
fundamentally we don't even we don't
know what those particles are made up of
we don't know why gravity is so weird we
know some
fun things we know the speed of gravity
have you ever heard of the speed of
gravity
but I don't know
so if the sun disappeared which you've
probably heard before like if the sun
disappeared they talk about how it would
take
eight minutes for us to know because it
would take that much time for the the
lack of light to get to us because the
light from the sun usually takes eight
minutes to get to Earth
um but the speed of gravity is exactly
the same so even if the sun disappeared
the Earth would still continue to orbit
around the Sun for eight more minutes
not knowing the sun is gone just going
about its little circular or elliptical
orbit for eight more minutes and then it
would know and it would fly off in a
straight line into space
so there must be something to do with
the
energy or particles there's some
interaction that that happens with the
energy from the Sun and gravity they're
obviously Inseparable yeah yeah yeah
exactly I love this like the like
looking up with wide eyes
that was like my entire childhood all
through college and I think that's why I
stuck with physics but that look on your
face is just I I live for it once people
start to think about physics in a
slightly different way but yeah there's
there's a totally different way to think
about gravity than most people think
they're like oh it's just a force that
holds you in your seat so you don't
start floating into the upper atmosphere
and often to the void of space but you
could think of it as this warping of
space and time so if you imagine all of
space like this sort of warpable fabric
it's stretchable and bendable and the
sun sitting there is is is warping it a
significant amount because the sun just
has so much mass which we don't know we
don't know what mass is there it is
again
and then if you remove that then that
Ripple of the sun disappearing will
travel through that fabric and it takes
some time to get to us and the time it
takes is exactly the same as the speed
of light
so the speed of gravity it turns out is
exactly the same as the speed of light
we just never talk about the speed of
gravity wow so is there a chance then
that we've given this thing called this
this um
we've given this experience on Earth of
weight
we've given it a title called gravity
yes but it might be kind of an obsolete
description of the experience of weight
in the future the funny thing about like
there have been a lot of times
throughout my education where I've been
like oh so everything they taught me is
wrong and then I got to this pretentious
moment of like once you learn about
Einstein's theories of gravity versus
Newton's Theory like three laws of
physics you're like oh well Newton was
wrong why did they teach me all this
incorrect physics because Einstein
really has the real law and he's
correcting Newton's Law whatever you get
to this point where you're like oh they
taught me something wrong but they
didn't actually your your science
teachers weren't actually teaching you
something wrong they're teaching you
something relevant to your daily
experiences like the truth of it is if
you accelerate your car on the racetrack
the force you have to push is you know
if people say it's related to the mass
of your car and you and then the force
that you push it with if you asked
Einstein he'd be like actually there's
all this other relativity stuff that
goes into the calculation f equals m a
and f equals m a is not all the whole
story if you got close to the speed of
light in your car then the force you put
in doesn't really give you much more
acceleration because your car actually
gets more massive the faster you're
going and so that M changes as that's
that's relativity but the point is like
you don't experience that on a daily
basis when you accelerate in your car
maybe you feel pushed back in your seat
but you don't feel like suddenly you are
a thousand times a million times heavier
but that's what happens when you get to
these extreme speeds where you need to
bring in relativity Newtonian physics
and then quantum theory seems to be a
leap and they don't
they don't Jive there's there's things
about the two right that don't drive and
they they are separate theories
essentially and may is in so now in the
middle is that Einstein because Einstein
acknowledged quantum theory but it was
spooky things happening yeah yeah that's
what he said right something along those
lines yeah he didn't like a lot of
quantum physics right but he was kind of
this in between phase between Newtonian
physics and quantum theory is that
Einstein's in the middle is Einstein the
one that had sort of like the cloth
essentially and then inside like you put
a ball which would be the Sun and then
it creates sort of a warp in the in the
clock and that is explaining sort of
gravitational pulls is that the more
mass there is which we don't understand
yet apparently the more mass there is
the more gravitational pull there is and
that's why planets all kind of
gravitationally pull towards the sun
because yeah there's Mass there so
that's kind of like the visual of how
time space fabric warps with mass yeah
that's exactly it did that
um I don't know if Einstein did that
that specific uh experiment like the
demonstration to be like this is what I
mean but if he had it would have been a
good explanation because that that's
exactly what I was talking about like
warping space and you're actually also
warping time which is a whole other
concept that's oh we're going to talk
about time
difficult to wrap your brain around but
when Einstein it was Einstein's theory
of general relativity so yeah one of
Einstein's theories of Relativity was
the one that talks about this curvature
of space-time explaining gravity in a
different way and
um and so you're so you're asking about
like two different theories that don't
mesh and there's we've still haven't
figured out how to unify them you're
probably thinking of um quantum physics
and relativity and the reason those
don't mesh is that quantum physics the
the name quanta is like little things so
it's not little things like like your
phone it's little things like you will
never be able to see them they're so
small atoms electrons
um quarks subatomic particles so that's
this is the physics and when I say
physics you ask like what is physics
really it's like a beautiful language
usually of math but sometimes if
somebody who just likes to blabber on
about it a beautiful language about
um about how those things interact and
how they work and if you give them a
little flick where does it go what
happens to it and with quantum physics
the rules of licking a little particle
and seeing where it goes are so wonky
that you will you won't know where that
particle goes it might tunnel through a
barrier it might yeah it might like like
as if this you know
the plant on your wall could just move
through the wall all of a sudden those
types of things happen on the quantum
scale so weird things happen and you
need special math to describe those
weird behaviors so that's quantum
physics and then over here is the
opposite so it's the opposite of like
something really tiny would be something
really really big something big enough
to noticeably affect this the curvature
of space and time those are things like
black holes the sun neutron stars uh
white holes I don't know that's actually
a real thing
um uh but uh
yeah supernovas like the most massive
things in the universe are described by
the language of general relativity and
we still have not been able to unify
those there's some places where the
languages don't match is as if you you
translate them and the words don't mean
the same thing so but it mathematically
so so that would be like in one place
you get a zero on in these equations
another place you get an Infinity in
these equations and you're like
um well which one's right and the truth
is that we don't know in the small cases
quantum theory seems to be very right
based on all of our experiments and in
the big cases
the relativity seems to be right based
on all of our experiments and
observations and and uh we're still
looking for that math that can bridge
the gap
do you think that's the theory of
everything that ends up bridging that
yeah yeah
okay so I've been thinking about this a
lot because I love this stuff and I
talked to various different people
within this realm
I'm just so curious when you're thinking
like is it in the shower one day it
comes to you and you're like what how
does because I I know that as a
physicist I'm I'm constantly asking
these questions but the number of people
that tell me like oh I just wasn't
interested in that stuff but obviously
you didn't pursue a career in physics
and science so what what gets you
interested when are you thinking about
these things I like to know how things
work I'm always very curious how things
work even if a friend has an issue a
problem emotional whatever I want to
know why I'm like well what you know
I'll dive in and like really kind of
excavate so The Logical logical brain
there so I'd just like to know how
things work and I believe that when we
know how
the universe works we know how to live
our life better like what if we really
knew that thoughts what if we really
totally believed I think we can know
that thoughts thoughts create things but
what if we just knew it and believed it
to our core like the entire fabric of
reality changes once you know how to use
the nature of reality to better your
life and better of the other people's
lives yeah no we kind of if we could
figure these if we could answer these
questions then we would know how to live
our life
bigger better and more efficiently
it's so funny that that you jumped to
talking about sort of you know a friend
having relationship problems and wanting
to know how that works and I feel like
some people think that you're either one
kind of science person or the other
where you have interpersonal skills and
you can't be both
um but I find that even in my even in my
my everyday interactions where I'm
calling my mom and she's upset that the
the my dad didn't fix the horse's gate
or something and I'm like well why what
happened like what what led to that
experience and how does the gate work
and like I wanna I wanna understand
you know maybe why they're arguing and
then in the end why I'm I'm dragged into
it and why I'm arguing with like I wanna
I wanna understand people and how they
think and how they work and I think it's
a very similar similar curiosity to How
the Universe works so yeah still the
same and I don't know if you experience
the same I mean this isn't scientific
but it's kind of explaining this sort of
curiosity is that I've explored kind of
the nature of empathy and there are
different kinds of empaths and one of
the forms of empaths they just want to
know how and why so it seems
a little colder or a little bit less
emotionally connected to start asking
questions but that's the nature of that
empathy is like I want to understand
yeah yeah absolutely so I don't me I
don't like feel someone's emotions but I
kind of am aware of how they feel and
then I want to understand why and I feel
like you sound like the version of me
that I'm always trying to convince
people that that I'm I'm not but I
really am because they already put me in
this box there like you're a scientist
you must like when someone's upset or
something and I'm asking questions and I
want to understand they're like oh you
like you must just think logically and
you're not there and I'm like no I
really want to know what's going on
because I want to be able to I want to
be able to like imagine okay if I went
through this like a and then B and then
I did see and then someone told me D
then I I would feel this way and I can
understand like get to the place where
they're at and it's like a a version of
of empathizing with them on a deeper
level I think
one of my favorite
uh videos that I've ever made and people
that I've ever worked with um have you
heard of Rodney Mullen
no
so he's basically the
um the Tony Hawk of Street skating so so
okay one of the grandfathers the fathers
of modern Street skating like the the
flat ground Ollie and the kickflip he
invented all of those tricks
um but he's just I you know any
skateboarder you talk to is like oh my
God Rodney Mullen like he's a hero truly
um so I got the opportunity to work with
him on a video and I was terrified
because I was thinking like ah I want to
do really right by the father of modern
skating he's so revered and so talented
and I started watching all these videos
about his original tricks and how he
thought and and I watched his old like
you know these videos are our kids
skating on Industrial pipes and there's
like Blink 182 playing and I'm this
physicist sitting there watching this us
but but what I realized is I was looking
at his world trying to find the physics
in it and trying to find the science in
what he does and by the time I got there
to meeting him I was like yo did you
know this about your trick and the that
when you kick like this what it's doing
is this flip and and it does it can't
spin like this and so you have to play
and he was like whoa I he loves physics
as well so he's like well I never
thought about it like that
um and I was there like I've never been
interested in skateboarding I'm not a
skateboarder but I'm so in love with the
sport and the way he does it because of
the way uh the way I could start to see
it Through My Lens and I think that's
I think that's one of the magical things
about about science and really any way
of finding a way to be curious is that
you can connect with other people you
keep asking questions eventually it'll
lead you to asking questions about other
humans and what they're interested in
and what they love and I think it's just
a I don't know I don't think this is how
most people think of science but I think
of it as another incredible way to
connect with other humans but through a
slightly different lens yeah high five I
agree I really agree
um which is why I would love to to do
the physics of with racing of racing
because it's not it's not something I
know anything about but but looking at
it to your physics like a lot oh my gosh
oh my gosh there's a million engineers
and oh yeah yeah tunnels underneath the
car that create like a vacuum to the
ground and did you ever get in any of
that like were you ever in any of the
experiments no I just would tell them
how it felt they'd been making okay okay
I'd go out and I'd be like oh my gosh
they might they might lower the end
plate skirts on the wing a quarter an
eighth of an inch on both sides and I
was like holy crap there the whole car
is so much more grip now I can you know
the front turns so much better I oh yeah
the minuscule minuscule different
differences with attitude of the car and
ride height of the car I mean I had one
time they pulled like a sixteenth of an
inch of shim it's called in the front
that lowers it a sixteenth of an inch on
a stock car which is a big car and I was
like and they actually they added no no
no they added a 32nd it was either 32nd
or 16th it was so minuscule and I was
like you'd never be able to see it with
your eyes no I was like you destroyed
the car I was like it's terrible go back
like it's so crazy how
um it the littlest things make a
difference
experimenting with you as as the the
guinea pig I love that there's these
engineers and they're like well you know
obviously we have to put a driver who
knows what she's doing in the seat and
get it going and then that's the real
feedback yeah I wonder if as we level up
our Consciousness if new forms of
mathematics
emerge like as we evolve do we actually
unlock the next
level of math and of about of and the
way that we think like do we need a new
new
arithmetic essentially new new math and
I just wonder if that's partly why and
so like the next level up might be The
Theory of Everything But then on on
ultimately The Theory of Everything
unlocks this next Dimension that we
don't quite understand right right I
love that I love that question I love
the thought that like we are it's almost
like I I feel like your question feels
like how we see with our three
um biologies not my thing but we've like
the rods and cones in our eyes and the
cones
um show us colors we've got like red
green and blue Combs but then there are
animals out there that have you know
five plus cones so they can see Millions
more colors than we can or billions more
colors than we can and so you know is
there like a
is there maybe like an a neuro
uh parallel to that where we're imagine
like a brain that has however many
trillions of synapses and things that
this is so far out of my area of
expertise by the way but I think it's
really fascinating to think about so I'm
gonna so uh let's just let's explore
together yeah let's play but imagine
that you had instead of your trillions
of synopsis you had like
five ten a thousand a billion times that
in your brain would you think about math
differently would you have to do
language differently like I think a lot
of sci-fi movies have depicted Ultra
smart beings where they're suddenly like
ultralogical and they can't have
emotions anymore but I don't know that
that would be
I I don't know again this is not my
expertise I was I'd got a degree in
physics and specifically studying stars
and dark matter so not how brains work
and how we will evolve but I think it's
a really fascinating question yeah it's
just a curiosity I have okay we've said
dark matter so I'd love to talk oh yeah
and um
I I've I've so many times of course
thought of like dark matter dark energy
I I use the parallel of uh junk DNA like
we kind of don't understand like 95 of
our DNA but we also don't understand
like 95 of the universe and I'm like
yeah exactly I'm also fascinated with
fractals like I I will talk about that
in a second but um but I think about
that a lot and I'm just I wonder of the
micro macro of of of things and if it's
just some kind of fractal Loop but what
is your understanding of dark matter or
even your opinion at this point in time
the your brain is so fun the like the
connection between unused DNA and and
dark matter that we don't even know what
it is
um I think that's that's really really
fun but yeah so as like a little
background to anyone who's never heard
of dark matter the way that I first
learned about it is that there's this
stuff out there in the universe one
thing it does is that if you look at a
Galaxy and you look at how stars are
moving around the Galaxy they should all
only be able to move so fast that the
gravity inside the Galaxy can hold them
going that fast and if something goes
faster and I get in a galaxy it'll fly
off just like imagine you're holding
somebody's hand on the playground and
you start spinning faster and faster and
then you like your sweaty hands lose
grip and you can't hold on it's the same
in a Galaxy where something going faster
and faster around the center needs a
certain amount of mass to hold on so we
look at a Galaxy and we see how much
matter is there we're like I can see a
lot of brightness so there's five
billion stars whatever
and then you calculate or you measure
how fast those stars are moving you
calculate how fast they should be moving
and you find that many of the stars in
the universe are moving way faster than
they should be based off of how much
matter is there to hold you know
basically the the hands on the
playground like
the the
galaxies are too sweaty to hold on to
how fast the stars are moving
um scientists don't usually put it like
that but that's how I like to think
about it I love like real life analogies
so so it doesn't make sense is what
you're saying you do the math on what
you're seeing in the universe and how
much
um how much mass there is based on the
mass and then how fast things are moving
they shouldn't be able to stay in orbit
to that sun anymore exactly yeah exactly
right so they shouldn't be able to stay
they should be flying off into space but
they're not they're staying in or a bit
so and sometimes there's like a hundred
times
too little Mass to hold on to these
Stars so it's significant it's not like
oh we found 99.9 of the mass but like
where's the rest no it's like we found
we we found one percent of the mass in
some cases like these galaxies are way
too small based up what we see and so
the theory we've come up with is that
there's extra matter there that we
cannot see and we've called it dark
matter so there's extra stuff there and
so you know these astute curious person
would be like well could it just be our
math is wrong or could it be like
something else is there that we're not
seeing like maybe dead planets that
aren't emitting a lot of light but we
have a bunch of other experiments that
show us the same exact thing we see
light curving around galaxies and it
curves too much we see that's the thing
light can do yeah yeah
is that a black hole I mean are we able
to see where all where black holes are
first off just being able to see into
the universe like that new Hubble can we
see the black holes like do we if
especially if light's bending is that a
black hole and is the black hole what
creates more mass because there's
sometimes everything up apparently yeah
I mean did you see a couple years ago
the first image ever of a black hole
came out yeah that was I mean that was
very exciting for the science Community
oh it was very exciting for the Layman
too because we've never we've never seen
it I mean that's I think like once
something is visible and you can like
put an image to it to like really wrap
your imagination around it starts to
become like the questions just start
yeah exploding in your mind so so what
you're seeing there is not actually the
black hole you're seeing light bending
around it so yes around a black hole so
yeah that could be something that's in
these galaxies that is not bright
essentially right or the entire or yeah
exactly so so we it could be a bunch of
little black holes that's one Theory I
don't remember all of the reasons why
that's not the leading theory why
tackles like if there's just millions of
black holes in every Galaxy that's not
the leading theory um and I don't
remember why but there are ways that
scientists roll these theories out I
haven't memorized all of them but
they're very fascinating and they're
very creative and and you should
Wikipedia them and spend a long time
figuring out why black holes are not
dark matter
do things orbit around a black hole
absolutely stars orbit around a black
hole yes absolutely black holes are
essentially the opposite version of a
sun and it the dark black holes Trump a
star
yeah because they're way more massive so
you could have a star orbiting a black
hole and you could have planets orbiting
that star technically
our sun is sort of orbiting a black hole
sort of because there's a giant black
hole at the center of our galaxy and
that's the one that they took the first
picture of so they weren't looking at a
galaxy far far away to look to find that
black hole they were looking at our own
Galaxy and seeing the black hole at the
center of it is there a black hole the
center of all of us as human beings not
like from a physics perspective but that
sounds like a a metaphor for like are we
all real dark inside the thing about
black holes is that generally they're
very very massive there are also
theories of like tiny black holes
microscopic black holes
um and so in my heart
but generally they would like they would
just travel through you and like gobble
up a little of you as they went through
they there would not really be much
reason why they would stay there they
would be pulled probably more toward the
ground and kind of gobble you a little
bits of you that's a weird thought but
like black holes like to eat everything
nearby so uh so I hope there's not a
black hole at the center of all of us
but we would probably know by now yeah
we do deteriorate we do but having not
been completely gobbled
um and not having a lot of evidence of
human gobbling I'm gonna say probably
not black holes but it's it's an
interesting idea but I will say about
dark matter that
um we have all this evidence that
there's something there we don't know
what it is but as you mentioned it's
like dark matter is a huge fraction of
the mass in the universe much much more
than like the you know atoms that make
up you you and me and our computers that
we're talking through in the microphone
you're talking on uh dark matter is way
way more than that so the fact that we
don't know what it is yet is insane
again maybe our level of Consciousness
uh so let's talk about fractals because
it's kind of like something that I think
about every day and I think okay okay
is that something that you are have had
thoughts or do you do any research on
fractals or not so much I mean so
there's a couple different a couple
different definitions of fractals one is
just like it's a mathematical shape
where you
um uh you draw a circle or something and
then you draw a smaller Circle off it
and you just get these really cool
mathematical patterns and you can
represent those with equations but I
think you're talking about probably a
different kind of fractal
I'm just saying repeating patterns
essentially like the repeating pattern
that sort of Loops through everything
and that essentially maybe the theory of
everything comes from figuring out with
this repeating pattern is yeah I mean so
many of these these big questions are
all theories like if we want to talk
about what we solidly know I can tell
you when you when you throw a ball how
it's going to move but that's not the
interesting stuff anymore like the
interesting stuff is the big questions
we don't have the answers well we don't
really know because we also don't know
about gravity anymore so and we don't
understand
gravity and mass really works so we
don't know you're right we don't in fact
know uh I stand corrected by Danica
Patrick
um I'm only going off of what you said
that we don't understand how mass and
gravity interact like act the same
yeah we don't we we still don't
understand what mass is we still
understand what exactly gravity is so
you're absolutely right but there are
different theories of how the universe
might end we've got a theory of how the
universe started with the big bang and
this period of intense like you and I
are currently well I don't know we're
probably I'm in Scotland right now so
we're probably wow I don't know I'm in
Scott I'm in Scottsdale Scottsdale oh
fine okay so I was gonna say we're only
like a foot apart which is amazing that
it feels like that but um no we are we
are many thousands of miles apart but
something thousands of miles apart at
the beginning of the universe would now
be billions of light years apart so that
happened at the beginning of the
universe we've got this
insane period of expansion we call it
the big bang and now we want to know
what will happen at the end and I think
that's a different question of the
theory of everything that's like a
theory of everything like what is matter
and how does it interact and what is
dark matter and gravity is like one area
of physics and then cosmology is like
where did we come from where are we
going that is a really fascinating area
of of thought and exploration and
research to me is what's going to happen
to the universe in the end there are all
these theories that it might just kind
of continue on expanding forever there's
my favorite Theory which is that
eventually it'll slow down in its
expansion because the universe right now
is expanding you've probably heard yeah
the universe is expanding but maybe
it'll slow down and come back together
and bounce like it'll come back together
and bounce and have another big bang you
know it may just keep doing that so
that's where I've seen repeating
patterns come into physics on the
biggest scale would be that's my
favorite and then of course there's the
there's like the I don't know like the
cold death of the universe or something
where it just like expands and expands
forever and then eventually there's no
stars near us and everything's dark in
the sky and it's very depressing so
yeah yeah exactly like when my brain
goes
there's no end it goes for infinity and
then I'm like but there has to be an end
but there's not and what is it and I
know I know that's where you've I mean
even if there was like a black hole that
created a loot even if time bending
creates like sort of like a bubble of a
universe what's beyond that bubble and
are there multiple universes is it a
Multiverse and what's in between the
multiverses I don't know I would love to
know that's one of the most I think this
is like as a physicist that's one of the
most frustrating sort of barriers I get
to mentally where
where if there if we have this bubble of
a universe or something and there are
other universes outside of it
here's the sad fact we will never know
because by definition our universe is
everything that we can contact we can
get light from we can see we can learn
from we can get like data from these
Stars billions of light years away but
if there's anything outside of it by
definition we'll never know about it
so that's where I'm like oh so
frustrating I want to know like when you
reach the limit of what we possibly can
know and you're like but but but why not
let's talk about dimensions then I mean
I want you to talk about quantum
entanglement
let's get into Dimensions so we have
sort of our our reality that we know of
that we can touch and feel this third
dimension which explain dimensions and
then how many we have
actually there there's a video I
recently made about this and I think
this is a probably a fun angle to talk
about Dimensions so have you ever heard
of um time crystals I have not but I was
watching that video
but I didn't get it I didn't completely
get it I was like yeah I'm very curious
about crystals because there's theories
that crystals kind of record information
and isn't there I mean things at the
subatomic level are crystalline and
structure is that yeah yeah yeah things
at the at the atomic level and the
molecular level are crystalline and what
that means in a physical sense is that
uh there's this repeating pattern so
you'll look at
there it is again yes
the moment you've been waiting for it
we only have 57 minutes to figure out
the Theory of Everything
it's going to involve fractals crystals
uh black holes dark matter and basically
when we unite the 13 crystal skulls
Thanos is Crystal
um fist yes I mean I have a lot I'll
tell you was there was a time Crystal on
the other fist uh but no what is a Time
Crystal uh so so crystals are this this
uh structure
um this sort of material that has a
repeating pattern so if you look with a
very very strong microscope at a diamond
uh you'll see this repeating pattern of
carbon well I think I remember seeing
that when in the video it's basically
like a grid structure exactly yeah and
there are bonds at the at the grid
points there are bonds yeah and there
are there are molecules between so
you'll get carbon and then with
different types of crystals like
tanzanite and rubies and you'll you'll
have different kinds of like silicone
and
um and nitrogen and other types of
things that actually change the color so
when you add silicone instead of a more
carbon then you get a green diamond or
something so when you with this
repeating pattern of of
atoms or of molecules you get a
crystalline structure that's a repeating
pattern in space and so
um what I asked my editor who I was
talking to in that video was how many
dimensions are there like how many do
you know of I kind of am very into this
sort of spiritual woo-woo world as well
yeah I'm pretty sure I think they say 11
or 12 Dimensions well so that is
actually not far off from a physics
theory and I will say like just as a
caveat that like the spiritual woo-woo
world that you could you call it
um is very it's so far as as far as like
the approach to describing things is so
far away from physics a human
experiential perspective sure but like
from a physics perspective is going to
be such a different answer so the
dimensions from a physics perspective
the three dimensions of space there are
three is you know forward backward up
and down and side to side but there's
actually a fourth dimension of space
time so the fourth dimension is time and
so a professor a Nobel Laureate at MIT
was like what what if just bear with me
what if we had repeating structures in
time
and that's where he lost me but he
explained it as like you imagine this
this very small system that just flips
to a different state and then it flips
back and then it flips like imagine I
don't know maybe
maybe you have like a a little I don't
know maybe imagine a ring on your finger
and the the gem just flips to the bottom
and then it flips back to the top and it
flips back to the bottom and it just
does that automatically periodically in
time he was imagining a system not as
big as a ring but on a really small
scale like the atomic scale as in the
repeating atomic structure of crystals
he was imagining this repeating in time
and so I think it was a really creative
way of thinking about dimensions and
thinking about what you can do in space
dimensions but now doing it in time
that's that's a a brief little sort of
mental fun play thought experiment for
what you can do with Dimensions if
you're using uh the time Dimension and
when things flip you're saying that that
would essentially be a dimension flip it
would be a flip in the time Dimension so
that repeating structure like silicone
carbon silicone carbon is like a space
repeating pattern but if you're flipping
this state
in the time Crystal then you're flipping
in time because you're going back and
forth and back and forth and that
repetition
so if it's not silicone are you saying
it goes to like something else yeah the
what they ended up making with a Time
Crystal was like Quantum atom there were
the electrons inside of a quantum
computer so nothing to do with silicone
atoms nothing to do with a ring flipping
up and down it's something like we would
never even be able to see it it's so
small and complicated but they would
consider a Time Crystal because it's
this kind of system like a ring flipping
up and down that repeats in time
repetition in time and they called that
a climbed Crystal it keeps going exactly
okay so it's not just it's just
naturally repeating in a cycle yeah and
it and and why it was so special is that
you sort of it doesn't take any energy
to do that
so this is like this was one of the
another question people love to ask me
all the time
um is whether we can make a perpetual
motion machine where like you you're
like okay but what if you could uh have
a a solar panel on top of your car and
you shine a flashlight on it
from the car and it'll just keep going
and power I'm like okay but the energy
has to come from somewhere it has to
come from inside of the battery so it it
it's not perpetual motion because
they're like but no but you connect the
solar panel back into the the flashlight
too and I'm like great idea but
yeah yeah there's gonna be losses along
the way and eventually the system will
die it just will no matter what you do
it will die no matter how many times you
ask me in the YouTube comments
so if we're talking about a loop then
and we're talking about time
time bends and that essentially yeah
distance or bending for a long enough
period of time comes back on itself I
would say do we know that no but they're
totally legit theories that
um if you bend space-time enough you
could come back around in a loop how
would you do that we don't know we how
would you like practically do that we
haven't found a way to come back around
which means like would you be
technically
coming back around and meeting up where
you were in time another re another big
question of the universe that we don't
know the answer to yet is why time only
goes in One Direction because in our
experience right you can walk back and
forward you could even reverse your car
on the track typically you don't I'm
guessing if you don't usually go
backward pretty much you do you don't
want to if you're reversing you're in
deep [ __ ]
has that has that ever happened oh sure
like you get in the wrong spot like
something happens on pit lane or
whatever go off the track and are nosed
up to a wall and you need to back up
yeah I mean you need reverse
this is an amazing day that I've gotten
to ask Danica Patrick if she ever if
anyone has to reverse their car you
cannot uh you can go backwards and
forwards in your car you can walk side
to side you can jump up and down but you
can't go backwards in time and we don't
understand why like it doesn't it's kind
of just our everyday experience but this
is where physicists love to be like but
hold on why would you just accept that
there should be a reason why we can only
go forward in time and we don't know
what that reason is yet so I wonder
again if time like we rethink gravity we
rethink time we rethink all of these
things I wonder I was listening to
something the other day and something I
think I don't know if it happens to you
but stuff like Words arrive in my head
and then and I hear them and so
time is a measurement this is what
arrived in my head time is a measurement
of entropy so it's like when you attach
it to just entropy then it it does
connect to moving forward like we think
of time as like there and there and
everywhere and forward and backwards but
maybe time is more just a a measurement
or an explanation for entropy I've never
heard entropy brought into the
definition of time but I I say that
because I think that
um I think it's a really really
interesting and useful way of thinking
of time and especially thinking of
entropy because that Define entropy
though just in case yeah yeah so one of
the other one of the other accepted laws
and in fact the reason why we can't have
a flashlight shining on a card
perpetually on a solar panel on a car
perpetually powering the car
um although you should pitch that to
yeah it's a good idea at NASCAR see what
they say test their belief in uh the
thermoological thermodynamics with a
slight powered cars
be like hear me out but really you're
just testing them so yeah entropy is
this idea that the sort of the chaos of
the the Earth the the the organization
of things in the universe tends to go
down so the chaos tends to go up
organization tends to go down and that
will always be true
um that's what we have observed we've
never seen it go the other way even when
you know one of the
things that confuses people is they're
like they look at a human they're like
I look pretty organized some mornings I
look pretty put together usually
um but like I have you know my eyes are
here and I'm symmetrical and I've got
two ears like this seems like a pretty
organized system that seems to go
against entropy but what they don't
realize is that you've created a lot of
chaos meanwhile you've uh your body heat
has radiated into the air in your room
and that's created lots of chaos you've
probably pooped a lot that's a pretty
chaotic hopefully that's a pretty
chaotic state of matter uh there's a lot
you've left behind that's chaos as
you've come into being this very
organized thing so overall the the
system of the universe uh the entropy
increases
um and or they say the entropy of an
isolated system increases is the
universe isolated
that's another big question like how
what's beyond the edge of the observable
universe I don't know we get older we
get older and it's essentially entropy
right like we are becoming less less
organized more chaotic we're sort of
deteriorating yeah yeah but if you also
think about the system we're in like the
rooms we're in the places we travel
we're also increasing the chaos of the
world around us I think that's a that's
a key I think that's a fun one there's
some good metaphors there too but that's
like a like from a from a physics
perspective you've got to think about
the system you're in and what you're
interacting with because humans are
obviously not isolated in like a bubble
yeah we are interacting with people with
other people and with with toilets and
with uh you know cars and releasing
burned fuels into the atmosphere and
there's lots and lots of chaos and and
um increased disorder from all those
things happening so humans are not
isolated systems like I'm coming
probably at things from a slightly
different angle and you and we can like
this is a co-creation this is like
that's what I think that's what life's
about okay well let's finish this off
because I know that you need to go but
let's finish this off with like making a
case for and against being in a
simulation oh that's a really fun one
okay so this is actually something that
I talked about and I I just filmed my
first ever show that's not on YouTube
um yeah
career changes it's fun stuff congrats
thank you yeah
um it's it's more of a math show and one
of the things that we talk about in it
is is an argument for us being in a
simulation and the argument tapping into
the I'm tapping into Quantum field into
the collective and yeah just became
aware I'm connecting with that
information here let me see if I can
remember how exactly the argument goes
because it's much more of a mathematical
argument like a probability argument
yeah go with your gut though I want to
hear what you think like what you can
just you don't have to get super sciency
if there is the possibility of us being
in a simulation then we would not know
because it would be Indus we're talking
about right like a simulation
indistinguishable from reality yeah like
we don't know we're in it and we can't
tell like Elon Musk said he said if if
you know games going where they work to
where they are now and essentially when
you when you project that out there will
be it will be indistinguishable between
reality video game and so that Likens
the probability that we are in the
simulation exactly exactly and I think
that that's I think that's the argument
for it like if there's the possibility
of getting to a point where it's
indistinguishable then we will get there
and but I don't know like what the
logical leap is to getting to the point
of like we are the then therefore we are
you know and and would in our simulation
we build another simulation like we do
we get to the point where it seems like
we're like imagine we're in a simulation
now and now we're building video games
that seem like a simulation and then in
that one do we build video games that
seem like a simulation
um I think the argument against it is
just
it's just a purely human
visceral emotional this feels like real
life it feels it's just like it feels
like I have free will do I I don't know
because we haven't been able to figure
out whether there's determinism we don't
that's more of like a philosophical
question but it feels like I have free
will it feels like I'm not in a
simulation but I think like
probabilistically it's it's likely that
if it's possible to build a simulation
then we're in one
yeah yeah right because the if you just
project the probability out yeah there
is that probability but I do I'm with
you I think that that emotional level
that that fact that the fact that we can
actually entertain the idea that we are
a simulation yeah yeah it's kind of like
if you can question whether or not
you're a narcissist you're not because
if you are you would never even think
about it or ask yourself about that no
so it's almost the fact that we can
entertain the idea that we're in a
simulation
for me
really is interesting I think when we
think about Consciousness I think
Consciousness is that X Factor in my
mind that's like okay well what's that
what the fact that I can be the Observer
the fact that I can have these
transcendental experiences or be able to
get out of body like what is that yeah
yeah exactly what what is oh my gosh I
think that's that's one of the the most
amazing questions in science that's
outside of physics but I would love for
whoever's feel that is to figure out is
what is consciousness what come on like
come on we all want to know like what is
self I and maybe these are philosophical
questions and will never be answered by
science but I like to think that they're
they're science questions and will
someday have a better understanding of
like who we are what self is I don't
know if it's going to come from physics
because we're way too we're way too
physically based and logical but I maybe
it will someday I would love to know
what who like what humans are what what
is we what who are we what is the I am
that I am situation I agree but I think
I just think I think that um I don't
think you're accurate in saying it won't
come from physics physics is is it um
finding things like dark energy and dark
matter or at least giving something a
title for something unknown you're like
there's this there's this equation we
can't figure out and so that we have to
give a title and a name because we don't
know what it is at this point in time
and that's physics filling finding blank
spaces where we're like okay what is
that and I think spirituality and
science go hand in hand and that I
really feel like a lot of times
Spirit things that cannot be explained
scientifically uh it's just a matter of
time yeah I I completely agree with you
and I think whatever time is and that as
we you know as we as we go along we you
know we kind of keep and coming up with
all these questions and it was actually
one of my first few interviews was Neil
deGrasse Tyson and oh my gosh
fascinating I was like holy crap this is
so great and he just sort of described
it like you know there's there's this
bubble we live in and here's the
questions and as the bubble gets bigger
and we learn more there's exponentially
more questions and so what is the
biggest question that you want answered
in your life oh the biggest question I
want to answer in my life I I feel like
I I could go two ways one is just like
how do you find happiness like what is
the true way of finding happiness it's
just something I think about all the
time and then the other one is why do
particles popping in and out of
existence in the void of space-time and
those are the ways that I live my life
how do you connect with people and have
amazing relationships and why does salt
decrease the freezing point of water
I love the way your brain thinks
I think between all of my Curiosities
and questions and your uh knowledge I
really feel like we could figure some
things out oh yeah absolutely I also
think that you know curiosity keeps you
young if you think about who who are
this the people who you know become the
smartest the fastest the people who just
like increase their intelligence the
fastest
their children because they're so
curious and they're constantly asking
questions and absorbing it and they're
never shamed for being curious they're
never shamed for asking a multitude of
questions across all areas of your life
um why why does poop increase entropy or
or why do particles pop in and out of
existence why is the sky blue all these
questions
lead to a lot of learning but I also
think that the Curiosity that is thought
of as childlike really leads to a better
enjoyment a deeper enjoyment of daily
life I really do
um I love that keep asking questions
keep asking questions cool well we
appreciate that you keep answering them
so
when you find those 13 crystal skulls
just put them put it together and we'll
we'll surely have some more answers
most excellent Danica this is so much
fun thank you yeah thank you so much so
and so informative and so
thought-provoking as well thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button